unbiased news is a myth ground news is a
news comparison platform that empowers
you to see how the political biases of
different sources are
influencing the news you read download
the ground news app for free
at davidpakman.com ground in a
desperate and pathetic attempt to shift
the blame
texas republican politicians and
right-wing media figures
are lying to their own residents
and to their audiences and claiming that
green energy and windmills are
responsible for the tragic power outages
that have been taking place in the state
of texas in the midst of
unusually but not completely unexpected
cold temperatures there and the reason
that they are so desperate to lie about
this
is that it's not just a matter of
accountability for the fact that there
are now millions without power and
without heat in texas
during some of the coldest weather that
they've seen in a long time
but their entire political ideology is
tied up
in government doesn't really need to do
stuff meaning
infrastructure spending green energy is
bad
their entire ideology is crumbling and
so now they are telling the lie
that windmills are the reason that
what's going on in texas is now taking
place and these people include
republican
governor greg abbott not telling the
truth it includes
tucker carlson it includes many others
the problem
in texas is not wind energy and we're
going to go through it today
and out of this tragedy there is the
opportunity to inform
about what happens when you ignore
climate science so here's what's going
on
more than 2 million people are or have
been without power in texas
why extremely low temperatures and snow
are affecting the texas power grid now
republicans are saying the problem is
wind power here is tucker carlson making
the case
good evening and welcome to tucker
carlson tonight happy monday well the
green new deal has come believe it or
not to the state of texas
and we're here with the report how's it
working out so far well the good news is
all that alternative energy seems to
have had a remarkable effect on the
climate as intended
last night parts of texas got to
temperatures
that we see in alaska in fact they were
the same as they were in alaska
so global warming is no longer a
pressing concern in houston
we've solved that problem the bad news
is they don't have electricity
the windmills froze so the power grid
failed now there are two big lies
there the first is that cold weather in
texas
disproves so-called global warming
this is an old one climate science
predicts
not just warmer global average
temperatures
but localized record highs and record
lows
more erratic weather what we would call
unseasonable
temperatures high and low so tucker's
first point is terrible
the fact that it's cold in texas doesn't
disprove
anything in fact it's predicted by by
climate science
but second secondly excuse me tucker
says the reason for the blackouts is
that the windmills froze
and this is so so so not true
as a reason for what happened and it's
important to have the facts
ice has forced some
wind turbines to shut down that's true
but wind power is only between 10 and 25
of the texas energy mix at this time of
year
the majority of the outages were caused
by
frozen instruments at natural gas
coal and nuclear plants that were not
prepared for such cold weather even
though they could have been
and again cold weather predicted by
climate science models for decades as
meteorologists quincy vigel
pointed out on twitter the power outages
in texas are in areas
predominantly powered by natural gas
this was not caused
by going green with some
of texas energy supply but republicans
in texas
desperate to blame someone else are
blaming wind power here is republican
texas governor greg abbott on fox news
last night
saying what we're seeing in texas right
now is a preview of the green new deal
what good is it sean this shows how the
green new deal would be a deadly deal
for the united states of america
texas is blessed with multiple sources
of energy such as
natural gas and oil and nuclear as as
well as
solar and wind but you saw from what
trace said
and that is our wind in our solar got
shut down and they were
collectively more than 10 percent of our
power grid
and that thrust texas into a situation
where it was lacking power in a
statewide basis
that was power that was spread out by
that ercot organization
or organization that you were talking
about and then here is fox and friends
this morning but he said for the first
time he's seeing a little bit of
california now
with what happened with the weather and
the wind turbines one of the things that
the climate denial
industry does is to sow doubt
and to claim that there are
controversies and unknowns where there
are not
this is a really old playbook it's
described in the book merchants of doubt
they did it with smoking when they
couldn't do it with smoking they shifted
to doing it with secondhand smoke
they did it with acid rain they did it
with the pesticide ddt
they did it with the hole in the ozone
layer they've been doing it with
various elements of climate change
create doubt and manufacture a
controversy where there isn't one
and i saw lots of people on online
saying i don't know you know there's
just
it's hard to know what the truth is
about what's going on in texas because
each side has their view
we're going to have to wait it's going
to take time to figure out what the
truth is about the role of
green energy or not in what is taking
place no
we have the facts making it confusing
is the playbook that they use a wind is
not even close to the main
issue and wind is actually outperforming
energy output expectations
for this time of year in texas blaming
the problems
of frozen instruments at coal natural
gas and nuclear plants
on wind turbine freezing shows two
things number one they're lying to you
and number two these are problems that
have been solved
in other states but texas has refused to
actually deal with it
if in texas they had accepted climate
science they would know number one
we should expect more erratic weather
and because that can mean really cold
weather
it means that we should weatherproof not
only the wind turbines
but the coal plant instruments the gas
plant instruments and the nuclear plant
instruments many other states have done
this
listen it gets cold in wyoming and
montana they have wind power as well
there are known solutions to this we're
going to look in the next segment at a
report from a decade ago
based on prior power outages in texas
saying here's the things you have to do
to protect yourselves from this in the
future
extremely cold weather affects natural
gas and oil pipelines because it changes
pressure
it affects instruments at nuclear plants
this is not
uh uh this is not new information and
this is not unique to texas texas could
have chosen to weather proof
not just wind nuclear and nuclear wind
nuclear natural gas
which are mostly their sources of energy
but also the wind turbines and texas
got crushed because its operators and
its politicians
not to be prepared for cold weather
that's the story now once people the
priority is getting people power back
once people have power back and are safe
who is going to be held accountable for
this because there are people
responsible
let's talk a little bit about the
history of this story in texas next
uh we are now uh we've already gone
through today
the false claims that wind turbines
are responsible for the power outages in
texas that's not true
while some with wind turbines did freeze
wind is responsible for a small portion
of texas energy
particularly at this time of year the
primary issue
was frozen instruments at unprepared
not weatherproofed a nuclear
natural gas and coal power plants energy
generation plants now not only
were we aware for a long time
that you should be prepared for cold
weather even in parts of the country
that typically don't have it
because that's what climate science
models predict warming overall
on the planet with increasingly erratic
weather individual weather events
in different places but 10 years ago
texas had this issue
and there's a very interesting op-ed in
the fort worth
star telegram out of texas which points
out
public and private sector leaders may
try to say
there's no way they could have been
prepared for this that's a line of
bull that no texan should accept this is
an op-ed from yesterday or today
in 2011 texas had what
is uh known as the epic storm that
ruined the super bowl in arlington
and agencies at all levels offered
recommendations to address the problems
that contributed to those outages
and that none of the recommendations are
not nearly
uh enough and not a sufficient amount of
the recommendations were actually
taken this was compiled into a report
a decade ago the report is called was
called
report on outages and curtailments
during the southwest cold weather event
of february 1-5 2011
causes and recommendations and that
report
pinpointed exactly where things went
wrong
how to ensure that it didn't happen
again in the future
many of the measures that were
recommended were not particularly
expensive and they were not particularly
difficult to implement
but they weren't done so not only do we
have lies being told
now to cover the fact that this has
nothing to do
with wind farms we also have the
negligence of a decade
to fix a lot of these issues other
states have done this stuff
like this isn't it's not rocket science
it's climate science i guess it's really
just basic engineering
generators can be prepared for winter
a lot of this stuff relates to
adequately
insulating and in other ways maintaining
different instruments at nuclear natural
gas as well as coal plants um
there was a list i mean look at the
report that the report is not exactly
exciting reading
but the report makes it clear what needs
to be done in some cases it's valves i
mean this is not important stuff it
actually reminded me
of the deepwater horizon oil spill in
the gulf
where a 500 000 some kind of
i believe it was a gasket or a valve or
something like that
a 500 000 modification 500 000 to each
of these uh
drilling platforms could have prevented
what ultimately was i mean what was it
was it
hundreds of millions i don't even
remember at this point uh
for bp what the total damages were the
environmental damage
etc uh this this reminds me of that in
many ways
uh also by the way even since 2011 it's
not like this happened in texas in 2011
and then not for a decade and then now
it happened again
and they opted not to do anything this
has actually happened to lesser degrees
over the last decade and texas still
didn't deal with it
so is anybody going to be held
accountable someone should be
the party uh that's in charge in texas
is the party that claims to be about
personal
responsibility we'll talk about one
texas mayor
who resigned uh in the last few days
after making
some insane comments about so-called
lazy texans the people that had lost
power
i guess that's sort of personal
responsibility but there needs to be
responsibility and accountability at a
greater level here
i don't know that there's an appetite
for it but it's going to happen again
we have an immediate tragedy we
shouldn't ignore that there are people
lacking power right now but once that's
fixed
what is going to be done because this is
a real problem and it's one where
solutions have been outlined they've
been sitting around you know
the trump administration had the
pandemic response playbook they ignored
it
these recommendations have been sitting
around texas for a decade
and now look at the tragedy that is
taking place
so we'll continue telling the truth
about the role
of different types of energy in this and
if you've fallen for the tucker carlson
greg abbott
whoever else fox and friends line of
this is what happens under the green you
deal in renewable energy
that's not true but ultimately someone
has to be held accountable for this let
me know who you think it should be
you can find me on twitter at epacman
the david pakman show at davidpakman.com
[Music]
the riots at the capitol made it very
clear that misinformation is one of the
biggest
problems that our society faces and
online filter bubbles make the problem
worse
making it difficult even for intelligent
news consumers to figure out what's true
and what's not
one of our sponsors is ground news which
is a platform with a really effective
approach
to combating this problem ground news is
the world's first
news comparison platform that lets you
compare
how sources from across the political
spectrum are covering a story
i use it myself i love it because it
lets me
easily see how different news outlets
are manipulating a story to fit their
own narrative
and it shows you your news blind spots
stories that your side of the political
spectrum
may not be giving attention to start out
2021
with a balanced news diet download the
ground news app for
free by going to davidpakman.com
ground the link is right underneath this
video
[Music]
the david pakman show at davidpakman.com
remember to grab a membership at
joinpackman.com support the david pakman
show get access to the daily bonus show
and if you would like use the coupon
code
to get a big discount off of a
membership joinpakman.com is the place
to sign
up uh yesterday as i've been following
the terrible situation in texas because
of a winter storm
people lacking power some lacking heat
and more
i came across a ted cruz tweet
that i found suspicious this is
republican
texas senator ted cruz who tweeted quote
today senator john cornyn and i sent a
letter
to president biden urging for governor
abbott's emergency federal disaster
declaration request
to be approved amid severe winter storms
across the state of texas now when i saw
this
i had an inkling that wait a second i
remember
ted cruz in the past when the natural
disasters were in some other part of the
country that he doesn't represent
i remember ted being against disaster
declarations and federal money
for the affected states so i went back
into the tdps archives and found that
yes ted cruz really is a disgusting
hypocrite on this issue
back in 2012 when hurricane sandy
ravaged the northeast of the united
states states like new york and new
jersey
ted cruz voted against providing
federal aid to those northeast states
why did he vote against it well he said
that the bill was symptomatic
of spending money we don't have in
washington dc
but then in 2015 when there were floods
in texas ted cruz wanted federal money
for them
and then in 2017 when hurricanes hit
texas
suddenly ted cruz wanted federal money
for texas
for that and this actually came up on
msnbc back in 2017
check this out but a lot of people are
pointing out that you voted against
aid for sandy after that catastrophic
catastrophic storm
up in the northeast that package back in
2012
uh and they're they're pointing at you
and saying you're asking for money now
when you weren't willing to help the
people in the northeast what do you have
to say to them
well you know look there's time for
political sniping
later i think our focus needs to be on
this crisis
that's right it isn't political sniping
it's a pretty simple question
of it appears that you can be counted on
to push for money for disaster relief
for your state but to stand in the way
of similar monies for non-constituents
and eventually ted cruz gives an answer
it's a completely bogus one these are
people who needed money and who needed
funding right after that storm i covered
those people
many of them just like those in houston
lost absolutely
everything they owned
well katie katie of course that's right
and and the accurate thing to say is
that i
and a number of others enthusiastically
and emphatically supported hurricane
relief
for sandy hurricane relief and disaster
relief has been a
vital federal role for a long long time
and it should continue
the problem with that particular bill is
it became a 50
billion dollar bill that was filled with
unrelated pork two-thirds of that bill
had nothing to do with sandy
and and what i said then and still
believe now is is that it's not right
for politicians to exploit
a disaster and people are hurting to pay
for their own political wish list
disaster relief needs to be focused on
the victims of disaster relief and i
supported that
for sandy disaster relief there and i
would support that anywhere there's a
major disaster
without getting getting distracted by by
political unnecessary pork spending
oh that bill had pork i
okay i see he's disgusting and in fact
politifact
looked at this and it's a talking point
that republicans
often used in their in defending their
opposition
to funding relief for hurricane sandy
some of them would say
50 of the 60 billion in that bill is
pork or
two-thirds of it is pork or 90 of it is
pork but the truth is that it was
all lies now it's not actually exactly
clear
how much of the bill from 2012
was specifically for disaster relief for
sandy
because there was money in there for
mitigation of future disasters
and as usual there is some pork but
that's business as usual that has
nothing to do with
where the disaster is that's sadly how
congress works
it's horrible but it's many of ted
cruz's own republican colleagues
who were responsible for a bunch of that
pork being in the 2012 bill
but here's the key thing um when you
talk about
disaster relief it should be part of it
to prepare for the next one when we talk
about coronavirus now
and the package that democrats now want
to get through it includes money for
rebuilding
some of the infrastructure that donald
trump destroyed getting rid of the
pandemic response team
throwing out the playbook all of these
different things if we don't
take steps to harden and make systems
more robust this is just going to happen
again
and the idea that that's why ted cruz
voted against it is absolutely insane
now let me be super clear
i don't want to punish people of texas
because ted cruz is a hypocrite
i want the people of texas to get the
money
i just want ted cruz not to oppose
disaster relief
when it comes to some other state but
defiantly defend it
when it's his own state that's what's
pathetic here and ted cruz has
a long history of doing this many
republicans have a lot you know we
we're we're talking about ted cruz now
because
he's involved in this because it's his
state now but the same thing happened in
i'm i'm going from memory here but i
believe it was in oklahoma
because of tornadoes when there were
republicans that were saying of course
we need the declaration in oklahoma we
need the federal relief money in
oklahoma they had voted against sandy
relief in 2012
for new york and new jersey i believe
tennessee i mean we'd have to look at
the full list but this is a type of
hypocrisy
that is not rare in the american right
and it's
absolutely destructive ted cruz is as
disgusting as the rest of them
donald trump is officially declaring
war on republicans yes
on i guess what is still considered his
own republican party
donald trump put out a statement
yesterday going after
many republicans but in particular mitch
mcconnell
take a listen to this donald trump
putting out a statement
through the save america pac
which is a pro-trump pac trump can't
tweet now
so he's putting it out through the pack
let's go through it and
and look at just the the uh double speak
that we see here all right let's get
started the republican party can never
again be respected or strong
with political quote leaders like mitch
mcconnell at its helm
mcconnell's dedication to business as
usual status quo policies
together with his lack of political
insight wisdom skill and personality
has rapidly driven him from majority
leader to minority leader and it will
only get worse so
trump here putting the blame of
republicans losing the senate
on everybody but himself this is common
trump does this all the time blame other
people
the reality is that trump's failures
including his failure on kovid
are a big part of not only why he lost
the white house but why republicans lost
the senate so trump blaming other people
he should be looking at himself trump
going on the democrats and chuck schumer
play mcconnell like a fiddle
they've never had it so good and they
want to keep it that way we know our
america first agenda is a winner
not mcconnell's beltway first agenda or
biden's america
last in 2020 i received the most votes
of any sitting president in history
almost 75 million now remember
he lost by millions of votes the real
story is biden got more votes than
anybody ever
trump goes on every incumbent house
republican won for the first time in
decades
and we flipped 15 seats almost costing
nancy pelosi her job
republicans won majorities in at least
59 of the 98 partisan legislative
chambers
and the democrats failed to flip a
single legislative chamber from red to
blue
and in mitch's senate over the last two
election cycles
i single-handedly saved at least 12
senate seats that's delusions of grander
more than eight in the 2020 cycle alone
and then
came the georgia disaster where we
should have won both u.s senate seats
but mcconnell matched the democrat offer
of two thousand dollar stimulus checks
with six hundred dollars
how does that work it became the
democrats principal
advertisement and a big winner for them
it was trump ignores
that neither david perdue nor kelly
leffler the two georgia incumbent
republicans who lost
were loudly out there talking about two
thousand dollars
understand that as well so putting it on
mcconnell from another state
when when uh it doesn't really bear any
resemblance to what actually took place
there is very weird
trump then goes on mcconnell then put
himself one of the most unpopular
politicians in the u.s into the
advertisements
many republicans in georgia voted
democrat or just didn't vote
because of their anguish at their inept
governor brian kemp secretary of state
brad raffensberger and the republican
party for not doing its job on election
integrity during the 2020 presidential
race this appears to be totally wrong
trump is saying the reason georgia
incumbent republicans
purdue and leffler lost is that georgia
republican officials didn't
didn't go with everything trump wanted
to try to steal the election from joe
biden
the truth is many georgia republicans
opted out because they were disgusted
at trump trying to steal the election
and they didn't want to reward lefler
and uh purdue uh by voting for them
given their alignment with donald trump
trump continues it was a complete
election disaster in georgia and certain
other
swing states mcconnell did nothing and
will never do what needs to be done in
order to secure a fair and just
electoral system into the future
he doesn't have what it takes never
didn't never will now this is of course
sour grapes
i i think mcconnell's disgusting but
mcconnell
has been an insanely effective operator
for the republican party
uh holding off on the senate the supreme
court seat that should have been filled
by merrick garland by
with barack obama's selection held it
open for trump to pick somebody
got hundreds of conservative judges
approved like i think mcconnell's
disgusting but to say he's been
ineffective
is wrong and trump this is just now sour
grapes
trump going on my only regret is that
mcconnell begged for my strong support
and endorsement before the great people
of kentucky in the 2020 election
and i gave it to him he went from one
point down to 20 points up and won how
quickly he forgets
without my endorsement mcconnell would
have lost and lost badly
now his numbers are lower than ever
before he is destroying the republican
side of the senate
and in so doing seriously hurting our
country
likewise mcconnell has no credibility on
china
because of his family's substantial
chinese business holdings he does
nothing under this tremendous economic
and military threat
funny how trump didn't care about that
when he was working with mcconnell
and had mcconnell's wife elaine chao as
his secretary of transportation
mitch is a dour sullen and unsmiling
political hack
and if republican senators are going to
stay with him they will not win again
he will never do what needs to be done
or what is right for our country
where necessary and appropriate i will
back primary rivals who espouse making
america great again
and our policy of america first we want
brilliant strong thoughtful and
compassionate leadership
prior to the pandemic we produce the
greatest economy okay blah blah blah
trump goes on with some stuff
that that is just his normal bragging
this is very interesting
first of all um i think that it's
important to
understand that at a big picture level
trump right now still represents the
majority of the republican
electorate 64 percent of the republican
electorate willing to leave the party if
trump starts his own party
89 percent of the republican electorate
wants trump to stay significantly
involved in politics
that being said i have argued that a
split in the republican party is good
for the left if the left is ready to
take advantage of it
the risk of course is if it goes
neocon versus q anon right
standard republicans and then the trump
crazies if they split if it's
q anon versus neocon if q anon wins
if it grows and wins it would be really
bad for the united states and the world
that's the risk
uh i don't believe that that's likely to
happen
but it remains to be seen as far as
mcconnell goes
you know if trump's going to primary try
to primary republicans
i think that big picture that's also
good for democrats and for the left
i don't think mcconnell really cares
about this mcconnell six years from now
when mitch mcconnell's 84
and he's running maybe for re-election
and trump is 80.
i don't know that this internal uh
challenge or threat from trump is going
to really be that big of a deal but
that's the latest for now in donald
trump appearing to launch
a civil war on his own republican party
very very interesting
and we'll have more coverage of this on
our instagram page you can follow us on
instagram
at david pakman show we'll be back right
after this
the david pakman show at davidpakman.com
[Music]
the number one funding source for the
david pakman show
has been and continues to be membership
and membership is not just a feel-good
thing
you get access to the world famous bonus
show every single day
just for members as well as commercial
free audio
and video feeds of the show day in
and day out you can sign up for
membership very very quickly
at joinpacman.com that's join pakman.com
if the normal prices strike you is high
by all means use the coupon code
better21 all one word all lowercase
become a member today
welcome back to the david pakman show
there is a stunning new claim
in an upcoming book that former uh
trump advisor strategist and really
insider steve bannon believed
that donald trump was already suffering
from the early stages of dementia
this is written up quite concisely in an
article in the guardian
by martin pangeli where the article says
former white house strategist steve
bannon
thought that donald trump was suffering
from early stage dementia
and campaigned to covertly remove him
from
office via the 25th amendment according
to ira rosen
a veteran tv producer ira rosen is the
author of a new book
about his work at cbs called ticking
clock behind the scenes at 60 minutes
he spoke to the yahoo news podcast
skullduggery and said to the host
michael isakoff and daniel claydeman
that his book was not meant to be about
any particular
person that it was supposed to be a view
about what goes on inside this role of
producer
and when the topic of stephen bannon
came up
uh ira rosen said steve is a big talker
a big gossiper
and he became a source for many media
people in washington
and uh goes on to say that
uh steve bannon quote believed trump
was suffering from early stage dementia
and that there was a real possibility he
would be removed from office
by the 25th amendment where the cabinet
could vote the president was no longer
mentally capable
of carrying out his duties he also wrote
that one text message from bannon said
you need to do the 25th amendment piece
by the way brother i never
steer you wrong the idea being to get a
piece
aired on cbs uh about the idea
this is quite quite early in the game of
using the 25th amendment to remove
donald trump um this is
so i mean listen there was speculation
about trump's cognitive faculties uh for
for quite some time and to hear that
someone so close
to trump at least for a period of his
president's presidency particularly the
earlier part of his presidency
where the concerns were not as great
about trump's cognitive state
uh it is it is stunning and it is
incredible now
there's a very cynical analysis here the
the simplest analysis the one that
requires the fewest assumptions and
complications is
this is really what steve bannon
believed and
he said it to ira rosen okay that's
that's the simplest
here's a more cynical analysis that a
few people emailed me
imagine that steve bannon wants to
help trump in some way imagine that it
is believed
that at some point donald trump is going
to face maybe multiple
criminal charges uh in the state of
georgia the state of new york we know
about all these different investigations
we learned last week trump is under
criminal probe
in georgia for that supposedly perfect
phone call asking for 11
000 votes what better way
to start mounting a defense for trump
than to start getting out there early
before there's even any charges um
mitigating factors about donald trump's
state of mind
and intent because there is no doubt and
i did this is
this is a cynical hypothesis i'm not
saying it's mine
it's one that i've been reading that
some believe
if you are going to prove some of what
would be the likely
crimes maybe trump would be accused of
and this is all very speculative
a lot of it will be state of mind and
intent what did trump believe he was
doing
what was trump's understanding of the
things he was saying and doing
if you can start planting seeds of doubt
listen even steve bannon back in 2018
whenever this
supposedly took place even then steve
bannon was talking about this guy might
have early stage dementia
that would certainly be a juicy ripe
mitigating factor
for a defense attorney that that's a
cynical perspective
the idea that trump's best defense if he
is charged would be some kind of
insanity to defense or or unable to even
understand what's going on defense
my view is that steve bannon had an
inside look at what we all had an
outside look of
and there were a look at and there were
real questions about trump's cognitive
state
the videos of donald trump saying where
is rudy giuliani when rudy giuliani is
three feet across the table from him
trump coming off of the plane and
wandering off
looking for his car when his car was
right there and a secret service agent
taking him by the by the arm and
bringing him back to his car
trump talking about the oranges of the
investigation
oh you know there's dozens of these
examples maybe steve bannon just had an
inside look at more of that exact same
stuff and we have other reports from
inside the white house that sometimes
when trump would say i never said that
it wasn't that trump was lying it's that
trump's memory was gone that's another
claim that was made by people close to
trump
we don't know we don't know um but
uh there are both cynical as well as
just very literal uh
interpretations and understandings of
what it is that we are seeing
alleged by steve bannon here maybe we
will learn more about it in the time to
come
today i have another beautiful
example really a perfect example of
these attempts to play
hardball with joe biden's press
secretary jenn
saki and it is not going well and this
one
isn't just fox news's peter ducey saying
something
obviously belligerent this is a reporter
actually trying to make something that
is not controversial controversial
the question is from owen jensen who is
a reporter for the religious channel
ewtn owen wants
uh to know how can we be sure that
covid's stimulus money in the planned
proposed 1.9 trillion dollar coveted
relief bill
how can we be sure that none of that
money will go
towards abortions now gensake does
something smart
she asks well what specific sections
are you even referring to where money
could go to abortion let's listen and
then discuss
go ahead in the back yeah good afternoon
owen jensen ewtn
global catholic network so regarding the
american rescue plan
groups like pro-life groups including
the susan b anthony list
very concerned that millions of u.s
taxpayer dollars
will go to the abortion industry in
violation of the hyde amendment
we know where president biden stands on
the hyde amendment but that being said
can this administration right now
guarantee if the american rescue plan is
passed
that no taxpayer dollars will go to the
abortion industry which component of the
american rescue plan are you referring
to
i'll pull it up right here uh a 50
million dollar funding increase for the
title 10 program
uh 750 million dollars for global health
activities and billions in funding for
community health centers without
applying the height amendment
well the president's uh view on the
height amendment is well known as you
have
stated in your question he also believes
that community health centers
are a key
part of addressing the pandemic of
ensuring that people in communities
have access to vaccines have access to
treatment and information about
about making sure they're healthy and
their loved ones are healthy
so that remains a priority to the
president he's
shared his view on the hyde amendment i
don't think i have anything new for you
so jen saki's later part of the answer
is sort of okay
but it's her earlier question that's key
she asks
what parts of covid relief are you
referring to
and the reporter mentions title 10
global health initiatives
and funding for community health centers
now two of those we can just dismiss out
of hand because there's no evidence they
don't make sense
he says does the money for global health
initiatives maybe go towards abortions
there's no reason to think that that's
the case does the money for community
health centers maybe go towards
abortions
absent some reason to believe that that
funding would go towards abortion i
think there's no reason
to explore those any further but the
interesting one is title 10.
title 10 is a federal grant program
that's related
it's related to family planning that's
true uh
and it is part of the program that
no title 10 money goes to abortion
directly it is true that because title
10
provides money for contraception and
family planning
it reduces pregnancies and thus it
reduces the number of people
seeking abortions and again some people
might say well listen
title 10 allows money to go to planned
parenthood and planned parenthood
does abortions but again
the the law is planned parenthood
can't use title 10 money to fund
abortions
so this is the same tired talking a
point a talking point
about federal funds for abortion that
religious media
and republican politicians love to trot
out whenever the president is a democrat
when there actually isn't anything to
discuss
title 10 money can't go towards
abortions there's no reason to think
that if the title 10 money is in coveted
relief
it would be any different than anything
else now one last bonus clip for you
from yesterday's briefing just another
silly question
a reporter tries to also play hardball
with jen
saki because joe biden's planned address
to a joint session of congress is
happening in march not in february as
some initially thought
and it just kind of goes nowhere sorry i
just wanted to follow up on
the president's appearance before a
joint session of congress in his prime
time address last month in january
reading from prepared remarks he said
next month in my first appearance before
a joint session i will lay out my
buildback better plan
so it feels like he did say it was going
to be in february well
what i was referring to is there was
reporting on february 23rd and i don't
know where that date came from which has
never been inaccurate so
uh it was the february 23rd wasn't just
an inaccurate date no one's fault it
just it just wasn't it created some
confusion so i was just trying to
clarify it
uh obviously the president looks forward
to speaking to a joint session we just
don't have a date yet for when
that will be jen saki continuing to just
be kind of like the mom
who's frustrated but trying to remain
patient
with her kids maybe it's just a
confusion
we're not blaming anybody the address by
joe biden will be in march
it's not a big deal and there are rumors
of course from
from washington that joe biden doesn't
want to do that address until coveted
relief
is passed and i would certainly
understand that because the longer it
goes without passing covet relief
uh the more of a the more of an early
stain that that will be on the biden
presidency it's time to pass it
it's time to pass it i said it yesterday
i said it the day before
i'm not going to keep going on and on
but it is time to pass covet relief
remember during their first year in
office
presidents typically don't do a state of
the union but they will sometimes do
a joint address before the house and
senate not
called a state of the union it could be
really at any time
and i am looking forward to seeing joe
biden's in march
but um really trying to create a
controversy where there isn't one
after the break we are going to talk
about the latest
fabricated scandal from right wing media
about the biden administration this one
is so stupid
that it really shows you the degree to
which the right is desperate to create
these scandalous narratives we'll take a
quick break we'll do that soon
the david pakman show at davidpakman.com
[Music]
the david pakman show is audience
supported media and you can contribute
any amount you want on patreon as little
as one dollar per month
plus you can get the daily bonus show
world famous at this point
and the daily commercial free tv show
by making those pledges at patreon.com
david pakman show this is audience
supported media we depend on the support
of our viewers and listeners
whether you listen to the podcast watch
on youtube or watch us
on tv or even listen on the radio
patreon.com
david pakman show
the david pakman show at davidpakman.com
donald trump and rudy giuliani are just
at the beginning of their legal troubles
you've heard a couple of weeks ago that
rudy giuliani is under
serious legal pressure for his false
claims about
dominion voting machines and their
alleged
role in the 2020 presidential election
now donald trump and rudy giuliani are
being sued
for their role in inciting the january
sixth riot and it's not just one lawsuit
there is going to be
in theory lots of legal money to be made
by lawyers defending these guys over the
next few years
if they actually pay their legal bills
let's talk about the two lawsuits that
are going on
first and foremost the naacp
uh has sued rudy giuliani and
donald trump as well as two white
supremacist groups
citing their role in the january sixth
insurrection
in addition to this a mississippi
democratic representative
benny thompson in his personal capacity
has also sued donald trump and rudy
giuliani this lawsuit was filed
yesterday morning in federal district
court for washington d.c
it says trump and rudy in collaboration
with the proud boys and oath
keepers conspired to incite the riot
to keep congress from certifying the
results of the 2020 presidential
election and it says that their doing so
specifically violated the klu klux kla
sorry the ku klux klan
act which is a statute designed
to protect both formerly enslaved
black americans as well as lawmakers in
congress from white supremacist
violence representatives hank johnson
and bonnie watson coleman are going to
be joining the litigation
uh as plaintiffs in the coming days and
the lawsuit really spells out
not just you know one of the one of the
i don't know about
interesting but one of the notable
aspects of the
case made against donald trump by the
house impeachment managers
in trump's second impeachment trial
which concluded on saturday of course
with donald trump's acquittal
was that the focus understandably
because trump was the one
being tried was on things donald trump
said and did
but when you step back from that a
little bit and you see the bigger
picture which includes rudy giuliani
it includes giuliani and jenna ellis
flying around the country holding these
bogus voter fraud hearings
which were not nobody was even under
oath they were not
uh formal hearings in any and any real
sense of of the word
that's a bigger part of the entire thing
and of course rudy giuliani talking
about trial by combat on january 6th
certainly a big part of what what we are
expecting
to see as part of this uh lawsuit
and uh this is admittedly a
statute the ku klux klan ku klux klan
uh act that um this is this is not uh
frequently used or cited but it does at
least
superficially appear to be relevant here
and it specifically is for bringing
civil actions these are uh lawsuits
these are not criminal charges now
separately as you know donald trump is
under criminal investigation in the
state of georgia
for that phone call he made to georgia
republican officials asking them to find
11 780 votes i believe is the exact
number the number he needed to
win the state of georgia instead of joe
biden
we know of possible criminal
investigations happening
in new york so this is likely going to
go on for some time now as far as the
lawsuit
for trump and rudy's inciting of the
riots
there is a real question there about a
possible class action for collective
trauma
i had a class action attorney email me
yesterday saying
it would be really difficult who exactly
has standing to be party to that class
action i mean there's certainly some
some questions there
uh but that is that is an interesting
legal question
there are going to be legal problems for
donald trump and people around him for a
very long time
and there is no doubt that for some
period
trump and and even the republican party
is widely speaking going to dodge
accountability in all ways in 2022
we will see for the first time
electorally whether some of these
uh people that came to power on the
coattails of trump i'm of course
talking about the uh i don't know what
what what to call them exactly but
madison cothor and marjorie taylor
greene and lauren bober
um we are if they got reelected
that would be a big sign that this
trumpian wing
is not going to suffer any consequences
for what they did in 2020
and we know that much of the american
public
has a short memory and that they may
have moved on to who knows what will be
going on in 2022 as far as
trump is concerned trump's legal
problems aren't going away
even if this specific lawsuit isn't
going to be more than
a small thorn in his side there may be a
hundred thorns
uh could be a sort of death of a
thousand paper cuts sort of situation
and certainly donald trump is going to
be racking up significant legal bills
whether he will pay them as always
remains to be seen
desperate times call for desperate
measures and times
are really desperate right now for fox
news channel
now you might be wondering why what's
going on why are things so desperate for
fox
fox news attached their wagon so to
speak to the wrong horse
that horse being donald trump and donald
trump lost the election
badly and then humiliated himself
and the american right by waging the
wacky
baseless fight to try to steal the
election from the rightful winner joe
biden
that we all observed together for a
period of several months
and this had a number of different uh
repercussions it led to many republicans
abandoning the republican party
but it also led to lots of fox news
viewers
leaving fox news for oan and newsmax
which more
reliably welcomed and pushed and
entertained any and every hairbrained
conspiracy theory
about the election so fox news is ad
dollars
are collapsing ratings for some of their
key shows are way down from before the
election
including the sean hannity program and
fox news is in a panic what do they do
what do we do they have been asking so
they are going back
to the strategy that got them to where
they are
in the first place manufactured scandals
about democratic politicians think
benghazi
think obama's tan suit think the war on
christmas
migrant caravans at convenient times
that type of thing
and the new one on tucker carlson's show
this is just
something else the new one that tucker
has concocted with his producers
is that the relationship between joe and
jill biden
that appears to be a loving relationship
a seeming return to a couple that likes
each other
which is a big change from donald and
melania trump's relationship
the claim is that jill and joe biden's
relationship is actually a
fake stage managed public relations
campaign
take a look at this at the heart of this
great american family is a love story
one man one woman in the fires of
passion that changed the course of our
history
not since anthony dine with cleopatra in
downtown antioch before they killed
themselves obviously
has a country witnessed a love story as
moving and poignant as jill
and joe's no ladies and gentlemen jill
biden is not
joe's caretaker she isn't his nurse
she's his fully equal romantic partner
together they are like besotted teens
yet at the same time
they are the wise and knowing parents of
a nation as a headline from politico on
valentine's day put it quote
historians and relationship experts
agree
the first couple's romantic gestures
aren't just genuine
they're restorative so it's official the
biden's affection is
totally real it's in no way part of a
slick pr campaign
devised by cynical consultants
determined to hide the president's
senility by misdirection
not at all their love is as real as
climate change
so i have a few thoughts on this this is
an example
of the performative outrage that we
talked about last week among the right
of finding things to be outraged about
that are just ridiculous and secondly
understand that this doesn't get on tv
on a whim
i i don't know exactly how many minutes
of commercials there are during tucker
carlson's show but if it's
similar to many other cable news shows
you know it's somewhere between
18 and 23 minutes of commercials that
leaves about 37 or so minutes of content
every single one of those 37 minutes is
very highly produced
meaning that this story was pitched
at some kind of morning meeting and as a
group they decided yes
let's go with this story let's go with
this story about
joe and jill biden's relationship being
some kind of
fake act and then of course being tucker
he has to throw in their relationship is
as real as climate change which is part
of how
they are packing up packaging up their
response to the texas power outages
which we talked about earlier in the
show
to blame wind power and claim that
climate change is fake but
understand the other part of why they're
actually doing this
they are panicking because not only is
their guy out of power
and not only have their guys followers
increasingly
opted for newsmax and oan because
fox coverage apparently isn't crazy
enough people also
like what joe biden is doing and this
has fox news in an absolute tizzy
joe biden has the highest initial
approval rating of any president in 28
years
fox news is panicking because of that
joe biden has 69
approval on his handling of covet under
joe biden
average daily vaccinations have gone
from 890
000 on trump's last day in office to 1.7
million vaccinations a day and
continuing to climb that's uh that's
basically doubling in 26 days in office
and they continue to accelerate joe
biden is
apparently eventually going to get
covered relief done without republicans
and the country wants covet relief
but fox news just continues to interview
republicans who are against it
so fox news has to manufacture
something and this is what they've
chosen to go with now
is this going to work to pull audience
back
from oan and newsmax i have no idea it's
hard for me to put myself in the mindset
of what
someone who used to watch fox news but
was lured away
by newsmax and oan like what exactly do
they want what are they looking for i
don't know
it's hard for me to imagine what would
bring them back since to me it's crazy
to have been lured away
in the first place but this appears to
be the way
that uh many fox news programs are going
and we predicted they would go back to
the same stuff
the equivalent of the obama wore a tan
suit and like the wrong mustard type of
thing
the manufactured scandals the fake or
performative outrage they're doing
the debt and deficit small government uh
the war on christmas and religious
freedom all of these different things
that they
abandoned for the most part during
donald trump's presidency so we'll see
what fox news
fox news looks like in two months we're
already starting to get a sense of the
playbook they're going back to
in the um uh aftermath
of the trump presidency and then the
next question will be
if fox does a what is it
that newsmax and oan will do i don't
know the answer but it's going to be
some wild times
we have a voicemail number that you can
call anytime that number is 2192 david p
i continue to hear from folks who are
not as convinced as i am
that a split in the republican party and
a trump party
would be good for the left here's a
caller asking about
exactly that issue hey david this is
stewart from wisconsin
so i what just watched your segment um
regarding the republican party
and 64 possibly leaving
for uh trump party right and i know many
say that is a good thing for the dumb
party
because it would you know split up the
votes of the republican party but i
don't know if that's the case i think
that
uh it may be the case that it's good for
the democratic party
however i think that this trump party
may be a problem from the standpoint of
violence
i mean can you okay uh so i think they
said can you imagine
take using one of my my phrases there as
i said earlier today
in the fight between neocon and q
anon which is essentially what
republicans versus trumpists would be
if q anon gets big and becomes
dominant on the right i completely agree
that there is a very real risk of
increased violence
in the united states as evidenced by the
january sixth riots
that's a different question as to what
it means politically for the left in the
democratic party i think without
question
uh if the right is fractured listen it's
already borderline
the right already lost the white house
and the senate in 2020
the way that they are currently sort of
assembled so
i think that already the ability of the
republican party
without some modifications to win
national elections is really in question
if you fracture it at all it is good for
the democratic party
if they are actually set up and ready to
take advantage of it there is no
question that there is a whole other set
of considerations and if you see
the q anon wing of the republican party
grow and become further weaponized even
against other republicans that they see
as traitors
it could be extraordinarily dangerous
for this country
and it will keep the hate group watchers
very very busy
for long periods of time to come so i i
don't disagree with the call
i just think the political
considerations are different ones we
have a great bonus show for you today we
will talk about joe biden extending
protections for homeowners
very interesting set of changes that is
being made
we will also talk about a warning that a
january 6th commission to investigate
the trump riots
may be quite difficult politically we'll
talk about why
and the texas mayor has resigned after
calling power outage victims
lazy at least the guys taking personal
responsibility right
all of those stories and more on today's
bonus show
get instant access by becoming a member
at joinpacman.com i'll see you then
thanks a lot for watching today's show i
just want to take a second to tell you
about today's sponsors unbiased news is
a myth
ground news is a news comparison
platform that empowers you to see how
the political biases of different
sources are
influencing the news you read download
the ground news app for free
at davidpakman.com ground